La Guerra Fría terminó hace ya mucho tiempo.
O al menos eso es lo que nos quieren contar,
porque en la vieja Europa hay una región
dónde la sombra de Moscú sigue muy presente.
Casi tanto como para decir que en cierto modo
la Guerra Fría sigue viva 3 décadas después
de la extinción de la Unión Soviética.
Y es, precisamente, en ese lugar dónde nos
encontramos. Queridos amigos, amigas, muy
al norte y encajados entre Europa Central
y Escandinavia por el lado “amigo” y por
Rusia y Bielorrusia por el lado “hostil”
se encuentran los 3 países bálticos:
Estonia, Letonia y Lituania.
(Los 3 países bálticos formaron parte de
la mismísima Unión Soviética hasta su desintegración
en 1991. Es decir, Estonia, Letonia y Lituania
no fueron estados satélites como Polonia
o Hungría sino parte misma de la gran potencia
comunista.
Pero, sobre todo, la cuestión que nos atañe,
es que los bálticos fueron, y lo siguen siendo,
un punto clave para Moscú, un acceso privilegiado
al Mar Báltico, un mar que los conecta directamente
con el motor de Europa: Alemania.
Además, las 3 repúblicas se han convertido
en una de las regiones más prósperas de
toda Europa. )
El caso es que por estos y otros motivos,
son muchos los expertos en temática militar
que consideran que esta región es en potencia,
un auténtico polvorín, un centro de profundas
tensiones políticas y militares. Sobre todo
militares.
(Lituania dice que dos aviones militares rusos
han violado su espacio aéreo - LRT)
(Aviones de la OTAN detectaron un avión militar
ruso cerca de la frontera letona - ERR)
(Estonia dice que aviones rusos violaron su
espacio aéreo, otra vez - AP)
Tal y como podéis ver, los países bálticos,
una franja relativamente pequeña de 175.000
kilómetros cuadrados -equivalente al tamaño
de un país como Uruguay- se han convertido
en todo un quebradero de cabeza para la OTAN.
Contrarrestar la amenaza rusa, proteger las
fronteras y limitar la influencia que Moscú
son los objetivos.
La pregunta es: ¿Cómo quiere lograrlo la
OTAN? ¿Por qué se han convertido estas 3
repúblicas en uno de los mayores focos de
interés de las instituciones occidentales?
¿Cuáles son sus principales debilidades
y cuáles sus principales fortalezas?
Y quizás la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Podría la OTAN repeler una invasión rusa
al estilo ucraniano.
Pues bien, en este vídeo, y desde aquí,
desde las repúblicas bálticas vamos a responder
a estas y otras muchas preguntas.
Así que... Arranquemos.
(UN PAÍS DOS SOCIEDADES)
Pensadlo un momento, ¿Cual fue realmente
la clave que sobre cualquier otra explica
el éxito de la intervención rusa en Ucrania?
Vale, seguro que muchos estáis pensando en
las tropas que Rusia puso sobre el terreno
- aunque fueran sin bandera - y en su mayo
r preparación y equipamiento.
Sin embargo, dadle otra vuelta: ¿realmente
hubiera sido posible el éxito ruso sino hubiera
sido por la existencia de grandes bolsas de
población rusa?
Pues bien, ¿Sabéis qué? ¿Cómo os quedáis
si os digo que este mismo ingrediente se encuentra
también aquí, en la frontera entre las repúblicas
bálticas y la madre Rusia? Fijaos.
(En Lituania se calcula que a día de hoy,
el 4,8% de la población del país es de etnia
rusa. Y sí, puede que esta cifra no os parezca
particularmente alta, pero es que Lituania
es precisamente la excepción, por el porcentaje
de población rusa en Estonia se sitúa entorna
al 24% y en Letonia aún más, un 25,2%.)
Por supuesto el que haya más o menos población
rusa en un determinado lugar no es algo necesariamente
negativo. El problema surge cuándo su situación
social y legal favorece las de su exclusión
y separación. Y ese es precisamente el caso.
Fijaos en este barrio donde nos encontramos:
Lasname. Este es un barrio de mayoría rusa
donde apenas 1 de cada 4 habitantes son estonios.
Aquí la comunidad rusa es predominante. Hablamos
de más de 80 mil habitantes que mantienen
fuertes vínculos de comunidad entre sí y
que viven en un auténtico museo al aire libre
de la época sovíética. Algo así como una
Rusia dentro de Estonia
Es el principal núcleo ruso en una ciudad,
Tallín, donde más del 30% de la población
es rusa. Hablamos de una población, y amigos
esto es lo importante que tiene características
propias muy marcadas. Fijaos.
(En los tres países, las zonas con menor
renta son precisamente aquellas dónde más
porcentaje de rusos viven. Y ojo porque no
hablamos de una diferencia pequeña. El nivel
de renta puede ser un 40 incluso un 50% más
bajo que el de las zonas más ricas y prósperas.)
Pero eso, eso no es todo. La población rusa
en los países bálticos funciona en la práctica
como una especie de segunda sociedad, o mejor,
dicho de sociedad de segundo orden.
Y aunque su situación, sí, ha mejorado durante
los últimos años pero las diferencias siguen
siendo siderales.
Aquí en Estonia, por ejemplo, el país báltico
dónde quizás más dificultades ha tenido
la asimilación de la población rusa, todavía
a día de hoy hay unas 70.000 personas étnicamente
rusas que son, literalmente apátridas.
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Unas 70.000 personas, en torno al 6% de toda
la población del país no tiene ciudadanía,
ni pasaporte, ni derecho a voto en las elecciones
nacionales.
Y tampoco es que sean ciudadanos rusos, simplemente
hablamos de 70.000 personas que no son ciudadanos
de ningún lado. Sin ir más lejos, aquí,
en este barrio podemos encontrar muchos ejemplos
de personas que formalmente no pertenecen
a ningún país.
Y sí, ya sé lo que estáis pensando: ¿Cómo
demonios puede ser esto posible?
Pues veréis, el origen de esta rocambolesca
situación se sitúa en 1991 cuando el gobierno
estonio tomó una decisión firme: conceder
la ciudadanía exclusivamente a todas aquellas
personas que fueran ciudadanos antes de la
ocupación soviética de 1940 así como a
sus descendientes.
Al resto, a los rusos que habían llegado
durante la ocupación soviética nada de nada.
Y ojo, porque algo muy similar ocurrió en
Letonia, un país de donde cerca del 7% de
la población se encuentra en esta misma situación.
Hablamos de más de 130 mil apátridas.
Pues bien, tal y como os podéis imaginar
esta situación no solo alimenta la exclusión,
la segregación racial y la falta de oportunidades
de este colectivo de población rusa, sino
que también allana el camino para que las
estrategias de desinformación y manipulación
auspiciadas por el Kremlin sean efectivas.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? En Moscú son perfectamente
conscientes de ello.
Precisamente por eso el gobierno ruso lleva
años intentando alimentar un sentimiento
de confrontación y construcción nacional
entre esta población.
Ahora bien, ¿hasta dónde han llegado las
autoridades rusas? Y la pregunta más importante
de todas: ¿Qué potencial tienen realmente
este tipo de estrategias?
Atentos.
(LA GUERRA HÍBRIDA)
¿De dónde viene, por qué tanto interés
por parte de Rusia hacia los países báltico?
¿Es acaso una cuestión de mero resquemor
histórico? ¿Es quizás para frenar la influencia
de la UE? ¿O se trata de una cuestión de
neoimperialismo?
Pues... Todo ello y nada al mismo tiempo.
Sobre el papel, amigos, el argumento que esgrime
Rusia es la idea del “mundo ruso” . Ahora
bien, ¿Qué es exactamente eso del mundo
ruso?
Pues veréis, Para Vladimir Putín, cuando
se habla de Rusia y del pueblo ruso, no se
habla exclusivamente de los rusos que viven
en la actual Rusia, sino del conjunto de rusos
que hay diseminados por el mundo. Y especialmente
en el entorno ex-soviético. Es por así decirlo
una definición ampliada de las responsabilidades
políticas del Kremlin.
(De esta forma, la estrategia de los gobiernos
de Putin pasa por materializar este concepto
de Mundo Ruso. De esta forma el gobierno quiere
vincular a la mayor cantidad posible de minorías
de habla rusa con la madre patria.
¿Por qué? Pues porque consideran que estas
minorías rusas son un medio político fundamental
para extender la influencia del país.
De hecho, tanto es así, que en guerras pasadas
Moscú ya aludió como argumento principal
a la hora de intervenir la idea de proteger
a sus “compatriotas”. Hablamos, por ejemplo,
de la guerra de Georgia o de las intervenciones
militares en Crimea y el Donbass ucraniano.)
Ahora bien, estamos en los bálticos. Y la
pregunta qué podemos hacernos es: ¿Qué
significa todo esto? ¿Cómo pretende el gobierno
ruso ejercer aquí su influencia?
Pues... Queridos amigos, amigas, bienvenidos
a la Guerra Híbrida.
(La guerra híbrida es un tipo de conflicto
no convencional en el que se busca desgastar
al enemigo combinando por ejemplo medios políticos,
económicos e informativos . Medios siempre
de corte no estrictamente militar.
Esto se logra, por ejemplo, mediante campañas
de desinformación, ataques cibernéticos,
chantajes con el suministro de energía, interfiriendo
en procesos electorales o apoyando y formando
a grupos radicales e insurgentes.
Todas estas tácticas tienen un impacto enorme
en la seguridad de un país y también en
la funcionalidad e incluso la legitimidad
de sus instituciones.)
Y sí, casi todas estas tácticas son las
que Rusia aplica contra los bálticos. Pero...
¿Quéreis algunos ejemplos concretos? Pues
fijaos.
(Informe: Hackers rusos se aprovechan de la
infraestructura lituana - AP)
(Presuntos piratas informáticos apoyados
por Rusia apuntan a las redes de energía
del Báltico - Reuters)
Y no penséis ni por un segundo que los ataques
informáticos son los únicos ejemplos que
poner sobre la mesa. Podemos encontrar muchos,
muchísimos más.
Sin ir más lejos, se sabe que el gobierno
ruso financió en secreto un grupo de webs
de noticias llamadas Balt News que eran, en
apariencia, independientes. La intención
era poder difundir historias y noticias dictadas
directamente por el Kremlin.
Todo con un objetivo:
Hacer girar los bálticos desde una cosmovisión
pro-Occidental a otro más pro-Rusia. Y para
ello saben que aún más importante que influir
en el estamento político puede ser hacerlo
en la callé, en la propia gente.
De ahí que sea tan importante llevar a cabo
campañas de desinformación, fake news, denuncias
sobre derechos humanos, captación de datos
o amenazas políticas y económicas.
Pero, un momento, porque estas tampoco son
las únicas herramientas de guerra híbrida
que Rusia emplea en esta región de Europa.
Hay otra aún más preocupante: lo que podríamos
denominar como la estrategia de la tensión
constante.
Amigos, la presencia militar rusa en esta
región es enorme.
Hablamos de una concentración de equipos
y tropas de tal calibre que muchos expertos
militares dudan de que realmente la OTAN pudiera
hacer algo para frenar una hipotética invasión
rusa. Algo más que su supuesto poder de disuasión,
por supuesto.
Pero... ¿De qué amenaza estamos hablando
exactamente? ¿Cómo es la amenaza militar
rusa a la que se pueden estar enfrentando
estos 3 países bálticos: Estonia, Letonia
y Lituania?
Pues bien, atentos:
(EL TALÓN DE AQUILES DE LA OTAN)
Estamos en la Base de Misiles de Plokštinė.
Situada en el oeste lituano, muy cerca del
mar báltico fue la primera base subterránea
de ataque nuclear de toda la Unión Soviética.
Este, amigos, era uno de los lugares con lo
que el ejército rojo contaba para desplegar
su poder destructivo.
Durante años este fue un punto caliente en
la confrontación entre el este y el oeste.
Hoy refleja como pocos el triunfo del bloque
occidental. Una vez parte fundamental del
mismísimo sistema de disuasión nuclear de
la Unión Soviética hoy es una instalación
abierta al público en un país miembro pleno
de la Organización del Tratado del Atlántico
Norte.
Amigos, durante décadas la OTAN ha sido y
sigue siendo una herramienta clave, un contrapeso
en el sistema de poder mundial. Democracia
y libertad frente a autocracias liberticidas.
Esto es cierto. Pero también lo es que esta
organización tiene debilidades. Puntos flacos.
Y algunos de ellos los podemos encontrar,
precisamente aquí.
(Actualmente los tres países bálticos cuentan
con bases y tropas desplegadas de la OTAN
para defender por tierra, mar y aire las fronteras
que separan el bloque occidental de Rusia.
A día de hoy hablamos de más de 35.000 soldados
teniendo en cuenta tanto a las tropas naciones
de estos 3 países como a las unidades de
apoyo desplegadas por países como Estados
Unidos, Reino Unido, Alemania o Canadá. )
Claro que ante un hipotético conflicto en
los bálticos, Rusia no solo gana en número,
también gana en medios, capacidades y geoestrategia
Echemos un vistazo, por ejemplo, al caso de
Lituania:
Este punto que estáis viendo es el corredor
de Suwalki, una franja de unos 90 kilómetros
que conecta Lituania con Polonia y el resto
de los países de la OTAN en Europa.
El problema está en que lo que rodea ese
corredor es territorio hostil. Por el este
Bielorrusia y por el oeste Kaliningrado, es
decir, la propia Rusia.
[Por cierto, sobre Kaliningrado hicimos hace
no mucho tiempo un vídeo que ayuda a comprender
el contexto general de la guerra fría báltica.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Pero no nos desviemos. La cuestión es la
enorme facilidad con la que llegado el momento
Rusia podría aislar a los 3 países bálticos.
Bastaría simplemente con ocuparlo o atacarlo
para impedir el paso. Es todo un embudo para
las fuerzas de la OTAN.
Y, ojo, porque no hablamos necesariamente
de una ocupación ni un ataque formal. Los
expertos militares apuntan a la movilización
de una fuerza aparentemente irregular parecida
a las que Rusia utilizó para ocupar Crimea
o desestabilizar el Donbass.
De hecho, una intervención de este tipo es
quizás lo que más preocupa a los 3 países
bálticos, no solo en este corredor, sino
sobre todo en sus partes del territorio con
mayoría de población rusa.
Pero, ojo, porque este no es el único punto
débil de la OTAN.
En los alrededores de Kaliningrado, el ejercito
ruso tiene desplegado un sistema militar avanzado
que ha creado una capacidad A2AD -anti acceso-
denegación de área.
(Hablamos de un complejo sistema que permite
impedir el movimiento a fuerzas adversarias
por tierra, mar y aire tanto en Kaliningrado
como en zonas limítrofes. Esto se logra gracias
a una red de sistemas de defensa aérea superpuestos,
incluyendo desde 2019 el sistema antiaéreo
S-400 ruso, artillería de largo alcance,
misiles balísticos convencionales y nucleares
-incluidos 12 misiles Iskander de doble uso-
y misiles de crucero.
También hay armas antibuque y antisubmarinas,
sistemas de guerra electrónica y, obviamente,
numerosos aviones de combate, cazas y tanques,
entre otros muchos equipos. Y no olvidemos
a la flota del báltico, que está estacionada
aquí para evitar que la OTAN pueda utilizar
sus flotas de la zona en su contra.
De esta forma Rusia busca no solo perpetuar
su dominio sobre Kaliningrado y proteger su
único puerto báltico que no se hiela en
todo el año, sino también mantener a raya
a los 3 países bálticos y, con ello, a toda
la OTAN. )
El problema de este tipo de pulsos y carreras
armamentísticas es que por un error, una
mal interpretación o un despiste en un momento
determinado las cosas pueden escaparse de
control. Ese es el riesgo.
(Letonia advierte del riesgo de un "incidente"
entre la OTAN y Rusia - FT)
(“Tenemos una crisis fronteriza, tenemos
un importante ejercicio militar en las fronteras
de los países de la OTAN, también ha aumentado
la presencia por nuestro lado, el lado lituano,
el lado estonio, el lado polaco de los guardias
fronterizos y las formaciones militares. Por
supuesto, esto está aumentando la posibilidad
de incidentes.” - Edgars Rinkevics, Ministro
de Relaciones Exteriores de Letonia)
Por supuesto, el argumento que esgrime Rusia
para mantener un enorme despliegue en la zona
es que bajo su punto de vista es la OTAN quien
tiene rodeada la región.
Mientras que para la OTAN, sin embargo, Kaliningrado
es una especie de fortaleza militar rusa dentro
del territorio del bloque.
Pero fijaos en este mapa. En él podéis ver
la enorme concentración de medios militares
que Rusia ha dispuesto en su frontera occidental.
Por ejemplo, en Pskov, a tan solo 32 km de
la frontera con Estonia, Rusia tiene desplegada
una divisó de asalto aéreo y una brigada
de las fuerzas especiales rusas. Los Navy
Seals de Putin.
(Sin contar ni siquiera con las fuerzas de
Kaliningrado muchos expertos militares apuntan
a que Rusia goza de una importante superioridad
operativa en la zona.
La propia OTAN calcula que los rusos serían
capaces de desplegar rápidamente entre 50.000
y 60.000 soldados en apenas unos pocos días.
Además la amenaza para los países bálticos
podría llegar desde direcciones diferentes
lo que dificulta aún más la defensa de la
zona.)
Pero, vale, evidentemente, hoy por hoy la
posibilidad de un conflicto armado es razonablemente
pequeña y desde luego no podemos olvidar
el poder disuasorio que tiene la propia OTAN.
Pero....Amigos los errores existen. Y no solo
tenemos que pensar en un incidente fortuito.
El importante peso que tiene la comunidad
rusa en Estonia y Letonia, su escasa integración
en la vida civil y política y su relativa
mala situación económica podrían favorecer
movimientos de choque, rebelión o protesta
que podrían causar importantes daños a la
estabilidad de los 3 países bálticos.
Esa es la auténtica amenaza. Y en ella el
juego de la guerra híbrida y la tensión
constante desplegada por Rusia es la mayor
baza.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Crees que la OTAN tiene que incrementar
su despliegue en su frontera oriental? ¿Cómo
crees que deberían los países occidentales
enfrentarse a una acción de guerra híbrida
masiva en los bálticos como la que ya se
produjo en Ucrania? ¿De qué forma pueden
acotarse los riesgos?
Déjanos tu opinión aquí abajo, en los comentarios.
Y, por cierto, si te gusta lo que hacemos
ahora puedes formar parte de este proyecto
y ayudar a que siga creciendo uniéndote a
nuestra comunidad en Patreon.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.